respect side dudes
absolutely have you ever been a side
dude I'm currently
hmm
[Music]
what's that like it's great okay tell me
tell me about it conversations are great
because now we can talk about the main
dude like I like that's how I do music
and like I even one of my balls I say
you took a Nobu I Hit It One team one
time he come quick like fast food
because you will spend like I said the
90 dudes will spend their hard-earned
paper their hard-earned hours taking you
out to dinners giving you all the
attention making you feel good about
yourself telling you good morning
darling and ground rising and giving you
all the morning taxes and she's going to
come and see me after
because I'm not giving it none of that
energy that's not what I'm here for how
did you meet her how did I meet her
um you're like how did you slide it like
did she have a man when you met her
um I didn't ask I don't ask there's no
need to ask because women know before
like you have like this
natural pheromone thing in your mind
where you can actually pick up to see if
a guy is sleeping with a lot of girls
with free isn't so when I approached her
I think I actually met her in the street
when I approached her
I think I was just doing my work like
because I'd be like promoting my music
out and about every day and stuff so I
pulled up on it and we just started
talking just having conversations and
then at one day the conversation just
went from
here to there like it took an a left
turn but sometimes you know where you
whereas men you take that risk be like
all right I'm gonna cross the line now
and and talk in that direction and if
she entertains it I don't need to ask
any more questions and it went from
there and now it's like we have a cool
relationship where it's like she'll be
telling me about other dudes or she was
out with this guy the other day and we
can just have an open chat I'll be
talking about girls that I'll be with
because well she got multiple side dudes
yeah she's got multiple dudes because
women in the top 10 percent because as
much as we look at the men and we focus
on the men ten percent there's a top 10
of women too this is why the beauty
industry is worth so much this is why
modeling and fashion because women
compete as much as they say they don't
want to that's why when you go to the
shopping centers it's mainly women
mannequins in the windows because
they're checking each other out they're
competing against each other so the top
10 of women are getting all the
attention from the men because men are
always going to punch above their weight
and women know if they're dealing with a
top 10 10 type guy or or a 90 type guy
and the Knight expense guy is going to
pay for everything
and the top 10 guy ain't paying for
nothing was going to get everything and
that's just how the deal has been set
same thing works the same way for women
and for men top 10 of women so the other
guys like taking around real dates and
all this stuff and like courting her and
then you're just smashing after pretty
much
like literally like they're in a
relationship like actual relationship I
don't know if they're in a relationship
have you guys ever done that
have you ever gone on a date with one
guy and hooked up with a different one
after
yes yeah yeah why
normal uh
[Laughter]
um because I guess the first one isn't
like a main
and you're just sort of keeping your
options open working out what you want
so it's kind of like the
the
guy after you already knew him and
you're like getting to know the the one
that's taking you on the dates yeah or
you might know both and you might just
be thinking I'm just could be date three
because you know what I wanted at the
moment there's already nine bills
why didn't you sleep with the guy you
went on the date with
because he courted you right
yeah
that's the ones that they don't want
they didn't go whoa
you spent way too much money there's
something that I learned I don't think
you
have to
I don't think you have to take a girl
out to get to get that I don't think
that's true
actual information right now it doesn't
mean that we're going home to my house
tonight to sleep together absolutely not
do you think that
um it's true that nice guys finished
last
by that because the guy that actually
took you on the date didn't get some but
the guy who didn't did
um
not always I think that women although
we like to think we like a bad boy deep
down we actually want someone to just
treat us nice do nice things the the bad
boys always all fun and games until you
actually want to settle down I think the
goal for you lot is to get the bad boy
to do nice things for you that's you
lots goal that's you lots kick oh he's a
bad boy but he's nice to me
no I don't think you want to ask me for
my number my boyfriend's a killer
that's what you like I mean violent
offenders have more children than um
felons have more kids than non-felons
you could say we have good taste in men
you could say women pick well you know
what I realized as well one thing I've
learned of something that I've always
been taught as well someone has told me
a woman told me this is that if a woman
doesn't sleep with you in her mind
multiple times more than three or four
times you will never see it in real life
I don't care what you give you could buy
a house car
and the thing is you know what's so
crazy
um Eddie Murphy's been saying this from
like dilemma like back in the day when
he was wearing leather suits you've been
saying the same thing he got his wife
from Africa brought her to America she
wanted half now yeah you get me because
she's hanging around westernized women
in the East they understand the value of
a man's provision they they respect it
women don't respect it anymore because
they've been given their own
independence but biologically in nature
is clashing with that and you don't
understand why yeah you're earning all
this money but you still want to be
submissive so you've got to kind of pick
a side that's why being a side dude in
the modern world is great it's great
yeah it's like it's like Tinder and
hinge and all these things with me I'm
curious hands who's been a side dude
hands hands up yeah yeah
why did I think I was gonna go this way
yeah is it really great because most men
talk about oh I don't want to stir
another man's porridge do you like that
is that nice okay
exactly men do not hold on hold on hold
on maybe he's got a boyfriend here
there's no way like I understand that
you can bang a girl that's got a
boyfriend but
bro I'm doing you a favor I'm doing you
a favor I'm hoping we get caught hold on
when you say when you say regularly see
you what you mean go outside dude like
she's got a boyfriend that she sees all
the time and she calls you up for sex
that's probably because they're not
having sex
that's why you're the same I'm saying so
as a man that I don't read that like I
would never be that guy it will it will
have to work at my convenience if that
was the case it's not going to be okay
so you're just going to call me from
anywhere and I'm going to drop what I'm
doing but I mean you have to you'll have
to work at my convenience
um I did I men would do anything like
honestly in reality you would never know
this is why I'm saying women have are
the best at being sneaky you would never
ever ever know I was the side dude
that's the that's the beauty yeah but
you know I know that's what I'm saying
you like so when I shake your hand and
say what's up bro hey nice to meet you
but we've got regardless if he knows you
know that's what I'm saying yeah so
that's my problem sorry you're right
we're stirring another man's party I'm
not stirring no one else you are she
just made another Bowl
that would be me taking her out that
would mean me buying her stuff
in his porridge like she couldn't she
might be telling you yeah she might be
telling you no we ain't sleeping
together we ain't having sex and then
you you were banging her that day she
wouldn't tell me that because you just
said yourself girls are so good at being
sneaky yeah you know what I'm saying as
the side dude you get let into certain
information so she'll let me know oh
he's coming around tonight you don't
know I don't know anything I don't know
any guy that really cares if another guy
is sleeping with a girl like this is
what so we don't I don't care like so
what it's only if you're taking her
seriously yeah yeah exactly I mean if
it's someone I'm trying to take
seriously then I don't want no one
around there but if if I know that so
you know so you know this girl is
leaving her yard that she's with her man
they could have just had sex and she's
coming to see you
and you're gonna yeah
if I'm single and I'm mingling yeah I
don't know I don't care
what you have to understand is most
girls have somebody else there three
even that's not what we're talking about
we're talking about a woman that's in a
relationship and you're her side but
that's no this is what I'm saying this
is what we're talking about you can't be
saying that you you don't do fit in
fingers you don't because you know you
know this what we're saying you know
you're the side guy she's got her man
and she's calling you up every now and
then to have sex how could you be okay
with that in yourself like like because
I think in my mind
yeah what's your issue
I don't understand like how you could
like enjoy that you know what I mean why
does it have to be on the same day and
all of that yeah but it doesn't matter
yeah well I mean if she's in a
relationship
but but I mean she's probably screwed
him that week
yeah but again why is he coming to me
because man ain't hitting it right every
girl has got that dude the one dude that
made you not that one dude exists in
your phone you know where he's at you
know where he exists you know exactly
where to find him you know what to say
if you call him so let's not play him
because it's a big risk for girls when
they take because like most most dudes
don't even know that women don't even
ejaculate from penetration
they completely Miss they completely
Miss foreplay but on the side dude that
knows that but listen she's calling I
can't relate you get it I can't relate
no I'm not saying everyone
like me when I've been single like I'll
have enough girls there that I know that
are submitting just to me
you can tell yourself that bro I know
you can believe that or you want to but
if you know if this is what it is if now
that what would make that true is that
those girls were five sixes and sevens
not necessarily because if you know the
game seven eights nines and tens don't
have one dude and if you believe that
you're playing yourself yeah obviously
but so we're talking about to accept
what I'm talking about is a woman that's
in a relationship doesn't matter you're
the side dude I understand
I understand what you're saying
okay it's not about wanting to be that
guy because once it's happened what what
are you gonna do that's what I'm saying
a banging a girl that say the girl
boyfriend that's one thing okay but if
you're then her side dude continuously
at what stage
at what stage do you become the side
dude what is how many how many times do
you go back
she's going on mums no no
I need to know how many times because if
just if we're just smashing then I'm
never the side dude in a sense based on
what you're saying because you're saying
it as if like I'm doing more than that
that's all that she comes to me for as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible